allison is with us in hammond louisiana
hi allison welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi thank you very much sure what's up
um so we just moved to louisiana from
maine about two months ago
me and my husband we and i've been
trying to find
a job down here that i like and it's not
working so now i have
two jobs i work monday through friday
i'm a tire mechanic at a shop
and then i work at a harley-davidson
store saturday and sunday and then i'm
actually in
the national guard also so one weekend a
month i'm going to drill
and i want to go to school but with
having a schedule like that
i'm just trying to break even on the
bills right now i'm not
trying to make a million dollars i mean
like i'm trying but it's not working out
but i don't know how to balance work and
trying to go to school at the same time
while still paying all the household
bills
and creating a plan
what's your husband mike um he's on a
tugboat so he makes 185 a day
he works 21 days on 14 days off so
it's a yeah
so he's making 50 grand he's making 40
50 grand a year right
yes about yeah okay and why can y'all
not make your bills if he's making 40 50
grand a year and you're working
yes um it's just
i don't know if it was because of the
move and we had to spend a lot of our
money to get down here and get all our
stuff down here
that we don't have as much saved anymore
how much debt how much debt do you have
we have two vehicles and i have
a credit card of five grand
and a student loan for five grand
okay what do you want what do you owe on
the cars
uh my car i owe 19 and his he owes
40 i think okay 40
000 and he's on a tugboat 21 days out of
30.
for that dadgum thing to sit in the
driveway that's dumber than a rock girl
i it's a you're going to be mad at this
part too
um it's a leaf and i don't know how to
get out of it
that was that's the main thing i would
love to get out of that you need to sell
both of these cars
the reason you don't have a life is you
gave it to the dealership
you're in slavery
both of them have to go so the way you
do a fleece and get out of it you're
going to get out of it if i tell you how
yes sir you can tell tug boy tug boat
boy his car is gone right
don't text him wait till
i'm serious this stuff is killing you
guys
it's not the move that got you it's
these cars you have
60 000 in car debt and your household
income isn't even 60 grand i'm so sorry
honey
you're i'm i'm just i'm mad for you that
they just screwed you this bad and you
let it happen
oh my gosh all right so how do we get
out of it so here's what you do you jump
online and find out what the stupid car
is worth it's not a car it's a truck
isn't it
yes sir yeah okay
we've been down this road a couple times
oh so all right so
uh me too i'm not laughing at you i'm
laughing with you i just it's the same
exact stuff i would have done when i was
25 are y'all 25
i'm 23. okay close enough all right and
so
um you jump online let's find out what
the car
is worth the truck is worth let's
pretend
that it's worth uh 35 000
where did you get 40 000 as to what you
owe on it
i'm sorry where did you get the number
40 000 that's owed on it since it's a
lease
um well we have we're gonna
so for the leaf aspect i think we only
owe
about 10 but it's over miles
so it's 25 cents per mile that it's over
so we were thinking that the cheapest
way
to get out of it would be to buy it and
then sell it
at the end of the week it may be it may
be the cheapest way but let's go ahead
and do that
now you don't have to wait till the end
of the lease okay so you
call them and ask them for the early
buy out on the fleece if you want to
give them a check and they give you the
title
have you done that is that where you got
40
no sir that's all together you were just
estimating
you were guessing okay how long has he
had the truck
two years what was the msrp on it when
he bought it
the the sticker on it 55
65. two years
that was a sticker on it we got it
knocked down
probably to 52. uh uh
not on a leash you didn't um okay family
friends on the
dealership yeah that they were so good
to you too
um yeah i know it's such a blessing to
have friends like that
um so all right so call them back and
ask them to take back this blessing no
they're not gonna take it back i wish i
would have heard of you
two years ago because i know you it's
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i just hurt i'm just hurt for
you and i'm just aggravated for you not
at you honey
i just want you to get out of this
because it's killing you it's killing
you you're working in a tire store
to pay for his truck so um all right so
call the car fleece company and ask them
what the early buyout is
i'm afraid it's going to be more like 50
grand than 40.
okay i don't know but you ask him for
the early buyout and that's like the
payoff
on a car loan that's the same number
okay that makes sense to you
yes okay then what i want you to do
is to jump on kelly blue
kellybluebookkbb.com
and let's find out what it's worth
and then you're going to have to come up
with a difference with a loan from
someone
if it's so if it's a 50 buyout and you
look it up and it's worth
40 then you're 10 in the hole
and if you get you got to write a 10 000
check in order to sell the truck
and you're going to borrow that money
somewhere but i'd rather you be 10 000
in debt than 50 which is what i think
you are in debt
i don't know well you'll have to get
into it and figure it out but basically
you've got to cover the difference and
you're going to be in the hole just like
if you had borrowed the money on a car
loan you'd be in the hole you'd be
upside down
it works the same way it's only they
hide it under the mystery and the fog of
a lease
but it's still all in there it's still
you getting screwed is in there
so here's what we need to do okay
um i need to put the two of you and he
is he got wi-fi available on the tub
sure i'm assuming he does
he has cell phone service here and there
yeah yeah good okay
i'm gonna put you two into ramsey plus
and financial peace university so you
can learn how to handle money
we're also kelly's going to hook you up
with one of our ramsey certified
coaches our ramsey preferred coaches and
it's going to be free we're going to pay
for it
to help you get out of this truck she's
going to help you get out of this truck
because you're so screwed in this thing
if we don't walk you out of it right
it's going to double the pain
or triple the pain and um so it's not
we're not making a dime on this we're
going to help you for free i'm paying
for all of it
because i know how scared you've got to
be yeah he's gone on the boat for three
weeks out of the four-week month
and you're over here trying to fight
this stuff off by yourself you're 23
years old and you just moved to a
strange town
yeah so we're going to love you kiddo
we're going to walk with you
i'm fussing at you but i'm fussing at
them for selling you this truck and you
for buying
it not because uh because i'm mad at you
or something i just i hate the injustice
of this in your life
and i want to help you get out of it so
chris and i'll take care of you we'll do
that we'll get you set up with a
counselor
kelly you can get her set up with ramsey
plus as well yeah and the main thing
allison is it's not always gonna have to
be this way young lady
but you guys are gonna have to lock arms
and get serious about this and do the
ramsey plus stuff together
yeah and you people these car
dealerships that's immoral
for a 22 year old young woman walk on a
thing and walk out with a
65 000 truck that's immoral
it's just wrong at some point you've got
to do business in a way that's
that's a blessing to people that's
immoral